Janet asks do you think trees get
lonely no because trees don't have
feelings
um I have mixed feelings about a lot of
the books there was kind of like a peak
tree moment I want to say my book's kind
of missed it uh my publisher is unhappy
about it but like maybe 5 to 10 years
ago there was like Peak tree right there
was so many books um there the Peter
valan and Richard powers and Susan Samar
being like the really outstanding
examples but there were dozens more and
a lot of these books kind of personify
trees in a way that I think many
scientists find
uncomfortable um CU trees are radically
different radically alien from us these
you know they're modular organisms that
they don't yeah they don't live and die
like us they don't exist like they
certainly don't have feelings and they
don't talk though they may communicate
we just don't have the vocabulary I mean
it's it's a real problem like talking
about trees cuz we
cannot avoid personification and and and
the book is my book is full of this
tension like I I'm skeptical of
personification but then I realize
there's such a deep history of people
personifying tree and the whole concept
of tree is an example of personification
so in the end I I I'm okay with it as
long as we acknowledge what we're doing
it's like we're limited in our own
imagination to kind of like describe
trees and maybe someday I don't know we
will evolve enough and we'll understand
that we ourselves
are you know super organisms you know
like we are our bacteria kind of thing
and um and think of ourselves as we each
individual as a we that is relating to a
plant as a fellow we and it can but for
the moment anyway I think we're stuck
with
personification so like mother tree for
example like that's a beautiful concept
it's a beautiful book um but I think I I
know there are some scientists and some
feminists and some feminist scientists
who object to that because
it's again it's sort of suggesting that
altruistic sharing or giving or the
different kind of metaphors people use
for this wood Wide Web is that's like
it's like women's work right it's
creating an analogy right that that
caring nurturing giving is women's work
and that we need to be careful of the
metaphors we use and so in my book even
though it's not like I call out anybody
it's not my style but in the end I
prefer just to call them old ones and to
capitalize it because I got really sick
of Grandfather trees there's a whole lot
of trees named after presidents and
dictators and you know discoverers and
everything um but I Shar the discomfort
too with Grandmother trees and mother
trees and so I thought old one maybe
that
works